Hello and welcome,
everyone. This is guest stream number
53.1 at the Active Inference Institute.
It's August 23, 2023.
We are going to be having a presentation
followed by a discussion around the
recent work of Alexei Tolchinski, a case
for chaos theory inclusion in Neuro
psychoanalytic modeling. So if you're
watching live, please feel free to add
any questions into the live chat.
Otherwise, we will now have the
presentation followed by a discussion
with our excellent panelists. So thank
you everybody for joining. And Alexi,
to you for the presentation.
Thank you, Daniel.
Thank you, Mark, for finding the time.
I'm very grateful and excited to talk
about this. Thank you, Andrea Brynn
Albert. I hope maybe Mike will join us.
And thank you, Daniel And, active
inference institute, for organizing this
meeting. So, can you see the slides?
Yep. Okay, so I'll just proceed then.
This is the outline of the talk. I'll
share some preliminary comments and talk
briefly about assumptions in the current
models, summarize the data, talk about
free energy principle formulations as
compatible with chaos, and talk about
some future developments. And hopefully
we can discuss that. I'm very much
looking forward to have more questions
than answers. I'd like to start with
what Michael Levin taught me, I guess,
is just why it's important to me. The
most important thing is the clinical
applications. I think that
with your work, Mark, and with Pang
SIP's work, we have been moving away
from dualism over the course of some
time. But I think the other big d
determinism is still highly prevalent
and dominant. And I do think it
influences our clinical work, diagnosis
and psychotherapy and assessments. And I
think that it may be beneficial for some
of the harder conditions we work with to
consider, including nonlinear framework.
That's my main focus. This is the link
to the preprint. And the paper is
published fully in Neuropsychoanalysis
Journal. Some of it is discussion
with this foundational paper that you,
Mark, wrote, the new Project for a
Scientific Psychology General Scheme,
which is a perhaps revision, a revival
of Freud's famous paper Project for
Scientific Psychology. And I'd
like to give you credit, Mark, that you
have been opening conversations between
disciplines that hadn't been talking to
each other prior to your efforts, such
as psychoanalysis and neurosciences,
you've been doing for more than 20 years
with great success. In the same spirit,
I wanted to mention that Society for
Chaos Theory in Psychology exists since
91, which is when their first conference
happened, about less than 20 years.
Then the first conference on chaos in
Lake, Italy, around Lake Italy,
lake Como in Italy in 76, which was
mostly physicists at that time. And then
psychologists joined. And I've attended
the recent conference in Toronto, which
was absolutely wonderful. And I've met
extraordinary clinicians and scientists.
And I think that it would be beneficial
to open that dialogue as well. And maybe
if there is a wall between us to
consider demolishing the wall.
In terms of intent for the paper, you,
Mark, pointed out to me that you've had
an exchange with Robert Gallitzer Levy.
For those of you who may not know him.
He's a psychoanalyst from Chicago, a
psychoanalytic writer and teacher who
wrote a book on non linear
psychoanalysis and deserves a lot of
credit for his advocacy and he's sharing
his thoughts. He posed a question to
you, Mark, of possibly considering
nonlinear components in that seminal
paper, your Project for Scientific
Psychology. And to which he responded
that the key point in such discussion
was whether the mental apparatus was
indeed nonlinear. So I took your comment
as a task, as a challenge, if you wish
and decided to write a paper about it.
I don't know if the data presented is
sufficient, but I tried, and very
clearly I don't intend to contradict or
criticize. That would be funny of me to
do. I'm hopeful maybe to add a branch
on this tree that you're growing,
clinical and theoretical tree. And
should you consider it worthwhile to go
in this direction we wouldn't have to
change very much because this is the
paper by Friston. Lancelot de Costa and
others called Stochastic. Chaos and
Marker blankets. Free energy principle
is compatible with the chaotic
attracting set. What I thought was not
present just yet was a formulation where
the attracting set experiences a phase
transition. And I took liberty to
ask Karl about it and he shared some
very nice thoughts that I will, with his
permission, share. At the end of the
talk, I'd like to cite
Maxwell Ramstead, whom you know, and his
colleagues from the paper and Bayesian
mechanics of physics, often by beliefs
where they talk about dynamics,
mechanics and principles. And in
physics, Kepler's work is descriptive.
It shows what the orbits of heavenly
bodies are. Mechanics are the how of
the dynamics. This is Newton's. Laws and
principles are prescriptive. They are
about why things work this way. There's
a certain hierarchy in physics where you
could derive the second law of Newton
from principle of least action. And then
if you have initial conditions, you
could calculate the dynamics. The reason
I'm mentioning that is, I think, Mark,
your new project for scientific
psychology is a high road. It seems to
start from first principles such as the
free energy principle and then you seem
to derive things down from there. So I
thought, why not try to see how the low
road may look like? If in addition to
these derivations and deductions and
declaration of what entropy should be in
the brain what if we measure it in
Animal Studies and Human Studies in
Health and Pathology and see what the
data shows and whether or not the low
road meets the high road in the middle?
Or perhaps something may need to be
added. I also like to clarify
why I spend time in the paper talking
about obvious things for everybody.
Here the axioms and postulates. And I'm
quoting here Edward Frankel, who is a
mathematician at you know,
Michael will forgive me, but viewpoint
is that one can say that some parts of
biology can be seen as based on
chemistry, which can be seen as based on
physics, which can be seen as based on
mathematics. So how do things work in
mathematics? We know that Karl Frieston
likes to translate nearly everything he
works on into the language of
mathematics. Classically there's
something called a formal system which
we can metaphorically compare to
building a house. So the foundation of
the house is a set of axioms that has
certain qualities. And then we build
things up using the logic of Aristotle.
And we derive things like theorems. An
example would be Euclidean geometry,
which is on the plane that is based on
five axioms of Euclid. That's the
foundation. And then you could derive
things like Pythagorean theorem. Now,
if we were to change just one of the
axioms in the foundation, the entire
house changes. An example would be the
fifth axiom of Euclid that parallel
lines essentially don't intersect. If
you change that then we could have a
house on the sphere which is Lobozevsky
Riemann geometry and meridians on the
earth are parallel and they intersect or
you could have parabolic shape where
parallel lines also intersect. So we'll
have an entirely different framework and
it may be naive to expect the theorem to
look the same. The Figurian theorem, if
we put it on the sphere is different,
the formula is different. I'm mentioning
that is because I love
multidisciplinarity and I think that's
the way of the future with that
sometimes when we cross over into
another discipline such as psychologists
taking mathematicals or physics ideas
then we may occasionally forget this
formal system thing. For example, when
we say things like human beings resist
or violate the second law of
thermodynamics then the
second law was formulated for closed
systems in the state of equilibrium such
as a sealed chamber of gas and human
beings are neither closed nor in the
state of equilibrium so it doesn't quite
apply. It's a different formal system.
One needs physics of open systems to
make a statement like that. So again,
in mathematics because you mark seem to
have taken us deeply in the main of
mathematics in your project you have
differential equations for action,
perception, precision you have mark of
blankets, random dynamical systems
equivalences, partial derivatives. Then
in mathematics people fix the set of
axioms, they fix the definitions and
then they build a theory, right?
So I want to be clear, I want to clarify
what are the axioms in the theory that
is built? What is the foundation? And in
the effort of time, maybe I'll talk
about just one of them which is Freud's
psychic determinism and this is a
question for me, not an answer. I wanted
to ask you because I'm assuming whether
you kept this axiom or you changed it.
So Freud said in the psychopathology of
everyday life that there is nothing
arbitrary or undetermined in the psychic
life. There's different versions of this
statement and it has been repeated by
generations of psychoanalysts over a
hundred years. And it became very
entrenched. It's sort of a cultural meme
and a major tenet of psychoanalysis.
If I were to give an illustration,
perhaps those of us who are not in
psychoanalytic therapy, then let's
imagine an analytic therapist hearing a
patient who intends to say same with an
S, but they use the word shame, right?
So such a phenomenon. First of all, I
think psychodynamic, psychopathic
therapists would probably say that's not
an accident. Okay? Accident is
not a used term in psychoanalysis. And
secondly, they will probably infer of
what it might mean, for example, infer
along the lines of unconscious or
emotional dynamics, emotional conflict.
Somebody else may infer that it may have
neuropsychological reasons. Somebody
else may infer that it probably is a
migraine. But what you might will not
hear in psychodynamic culture is that
that was an accident, that it was due to
chance. I think that chance accidents,
randomness stochasticity chaos are not
used, they're bad form in
psychoanalysis. And that is the
illustration of, I think, for its
assumption. Ultimately it's an axiom.
It's a belief that is not questioned.
If we were to translate that assumption
in the pristine language, this is the
long givan equation from which pristine
starts, which has notations by Daniel.
Thank you, Daniel. And we have the
change in the state of x equals the flow
plus the omega. Omega is the Stochastic
know, in Daniel's metaphor we have a
wave and then we have ripple. So we
would have to change the Stochastic
component if we were to go with the
Freud's axiom. And then if we do that,
we would find ourselves squarely in the
domain of cold physics, Newtonian
physics, Laplace's demon. LaPlace
famously said, give me a position and
momentum of every particle and I'll tell
you exactly where they have been before
and exactly where they will be in the
future. Now, Freud didn't make
statements like that, but this is what
would happen if you kill the Stochastic
component. I want to be clear that it's
not Freud's fault at all. Well, first of
all, you need axioms to build a theory.
He chose that axiom. That's the theory
he built. Second of all, it wasn't
exactly mathematics. And finally, the
zeitgeist of the time was deterministic.
Perhaps there were initial
derivations of Stochastic mechanics and
quantum mechanics. But Freud, when he
was learning the world of deterministic
physics, was dominant. And there's
an important nuance in this discussion
pointed out to me by the first peer
reviewer of the paper who said, listen,
if you have something that changes like
a Stochastic thing and then you apply
statistics to it, such as variance,
then the variance of a changing variable
will be deterministic. And then if we
look at things like words which are used
a lot in talk therapy like apple. An
apple is a semantic memory. It's a
category. It's a coarse grading already
from green apples and red apples and all
other kinds of apples. So in that
regard, words are deterministic things.
So perhaps when we have a dream analysis
session and the patient shares with an
analyst the movie that they saw the
messy irrational thing with images and
tunes and anything and maybe words,
even if they narrate it, then they slow
things down, they average things out and
they put it in deterministic tools,
which is words. So with some objects we
can apply deterministic tools. But I
want to point out that the foundation
that everything and anything in the
psychic life that all the munications
have no stochasticity randomness is a
very strong assumption. And I'm curious
what would happen if we were to allow
ourselves to see things on the sphere,
on the parabola shape. It's not a bad
exercise because the general theory of
relativity would not have existed
without these other geometries. In terms
of definitions, this is a familiar
formula that you mark use of Shannon's
entropy. He originally wrote about
telegraph and sender and receiver in a
fixed alphabet. But here if we draw an
attracting set which happens to be
Lorenz attractor in phase space and we
look at these I don't know if you can
see them, they're small. The white know
that's the initial condition and then
they spread out and evolve as time goes
by. But you can see the density of the
attracting set. It is higher density and
lower density. So we could calculate
probability distribution.
A slightly different question is this
what would happen if you were to change
the initial condition a little bit 1 mm
in phase space, different things can
happen. And one of them is shown in this
diagram that would be divergence. And
the formula here is initial condition
multiplied by exponent of lambda T. So
when lambda is positive, you have
divergence and it's called lapin of
exponent. And that's one of the criteria
for chaos. When it is negative, we have
convergence and when it is zero we have
equidistant trajectories, we have
Newtonian mechanics. This is an
illustration of a chaotic system which
is a great red spot on Jupiter. And it
fits perfectly the Friston's paper about
the mark of blankets and stochastic
chaos because that thing is stable. We
have been observing it for 300 years and
one could say that this elliptical shape
is the mark of blanket around the chaos
that maintains its integrity. It's not a
contradiction because in one spatial
scale you have mark of blanket and on
another spatial scale you have a chaos
within the marker blanket. This is a
convergent system that is a bit trivial
to all of you. This is a hole in the
ground and then surrounded by hills on
all sides and if you were to put a ball
on the hill, it's going to roll down in
the potential. Well, and typically in
phase space, we'll call the bottom of
the hole an attractor and we call the
hills repeller. Repeller is a term less
frequently used, but it's the highly
unstable point in phase space from which
things move away from and they move
toward the attractor. Now, that's just
one attractor. The interesting things
start happening. If you've got two of
them, imagine a second hole immediately
to the right and the boundary between
them may very quickly become chaotic.
Here's another illustration on a
convergent system from the active
inference textbook that I hadn't read
when I was working on the paper. I
discovered it later. The chart on the
left is the density. And again we see
high density in the center and we hate
lower density in the periphery. And the
chart on the right is surprise. We're
very not surprised to find a ball in the
center, and we're very much surprised if
it stays on the hill. And I'll read you
a citation. Active inference is
restricted to systems like that one on
the left, which counter random
fluctuations with their average flow and
thereby retain their form over time. It
may sound like the statement contradicts
what I said earlier, that FAP is
compatible with chaos, but it doesn't
because you could have different spatial
scales and convergence on one scale and
divergence on another. I also
historically think that we have been
studying converging systems mostly so
far. Now, if we move
from things like that, which is very
simple, to a mind or consciousness,
then I think that what we could be
looking at is this that's a landscape
with attractors and repellers that is
very complex. And I'm going to quote the
former president of the Chaos Society
for Psychology is that that landscape is
dynamic. It moves. Perhaps some things
on it are stable. If we were imagine a
clinical scenario where there's a
patient who is very prone to shame and
very averse to express anger, then we
could say that shame is an attractor and
anger is a repeller. But we work with
pattern things in dynamic therapy so
they could be relatively stable until
the work in therapy makes them more
shallow distributions. But certain
things change overnight. Some things
change in a week or during the course of
therapy. So I mean, strictly speaking,
that's a dynamic landscape, and I don't
think we model things this way. I'd like
to also quote Maxwell Rammstead from the
same paper that free energy principle is
a tale of two densities. It would be
incomplete to say that we just minimize
one variable. What happens is we
minimize the Shannon's entropy of
probability distribution over sensory
states, while at the same time we
maximize entropy of internal beliefs,
which is very important. That's
adaptation. If somebody has rigid
internal beliefs with sharp
probabilities and then COVID happens,
they will have lower probability of
survival. They're not adaptable. So
adaptability means maximization of
entropy of internal beliefs while
maintaining the forum means the
minimization of Shannon's entropy of
probability distribution over sensory
states. Here's another term,
Kolmogorov Sinai entropy that is not
intuitive and it's from topology.
The picture you see is the photograph of
the statue called Intuition outside the
Fields Institute of Mathematics in
Toronto. Here's a graphical
illustration. If you were to draw the
trajectories in phase space and surround
it by a certain volume, say a circle
with the radius epsilon, and ask
yourself what happens to this volume as
they evolve? Well, when it
expands, then you can have chaoticity.
When it becomes more compact, you can
have convergence. When it stays the
same, you have periodic system, which is
indicated on the chart on the right,
where you have a correlate of the
colmorphs in entropy on the y axis. And
you have this epsilon on the x axis. So
the flat line at the bottom where the
circle doesn't change is the periodic
system. Omogorovsina entropy stays zero.
The curved line in the center that
converges on a K is the proper chaos.
This is theoretical chaos. And the
upshoot from it is what Friston calls
stochastic chaos. This is chaos plus
noise. And then you can have pure noise
and then you can have pure linearity.
So all of these things exist, they're
all on the table. You can have geometry
on the plane, geometry on the sphere,
geometry in the parabolic shape. So what
does the data show? And when we look
at EEG entropy, people use approximate
entropy, permutation entropy and
spectrum entropy, which are all
derivations of colmorefsini. And the
first two are in different phase space
from the last one, I believe. Mark,
correct me if I'm wrong. You cite Go
serious study in your book Hidden Spring
when you talk about entropy and phases
of sleep. And they use spectrum entropy,
which is a derivation of colmorov Sinai
in the frequency domain analysis phase
space. So the data shows that systems
as small as the axon of a squid isolated
in the lab to single neurons to coupled
neurons to EEG, we have evidence of
positive lap enough exponents in some
regimes of operation with EEG. We can be
more specific. That algorithm seems to
be weakly nonlinear, while things below
alpha like delta seem to be more
periodic with noise. And things above
alpha such as gamma and high gamma seem
to be chaotic. So if we were to
summarize this data, then we can
say that comogorous entropy appears to
increase as generalized arousal
increases from delta to gamma rhythm,
comogorous and entropy seems to be
higher in healthy, alert, brain mind
functioning than in the states of coma,
seizure, deep sleep. And it can stay
close to zero in a coma or deep sleep.
The interesting anecdote here is that a
simple act of closing your eyes when
you're alert decreases Comography
entropy clinical applications are vast
and developing fast, for example,
except for clinical psychology, I must
say, in psychiatry and psychotherapy.
But in neurology, the seizure detection
on the EEG right now can be done with AI
with about the same accuracy as a human
neurologist. And that algorithm does use
chaoticity assessment. There's models
for Parkinson's, neuropathic, pain, and
I have other examples that I'll skip for
right now. This is a graphical
illustration of phases of sleep. And
again, it has colmob Sinai entropy as a
phase of sleep. It shows wakefulness and
then shallow sleep, progressively deeper
sleep and REM. And that's the time
evolution. If you move REM in frequency
to where it belongs to wakefulness,
then you'll see the same progression
that comographs and entropy appears to
increase as a function of generalized
arousal. This is seizure onset at about
second four. Seizure is a reduction in
chaoticity. Healthy functioning is
higher chaoticity than a seizure. This
is a coma, which is relatively invariant
theta and delta frequency. This is a
nearly periodic system with some noise.
And death is a linear system. It doesn't
change. This is persistent vegetative
state, minimally conscious state, where
researchers were asking a question on
prognosis of survival and they've
concluded that diversity and variability
of the EHE was the predictor of
survival. Higher entropy means life.
So the hypothesis is that chaotic
stochastic and linear processes as well
as hybrid ones, such as primarily
chaotic functioning with noise can be
present concurrently at different scales
of the brain mind or at the same scale,
but in different places or at different
times. I realize it's a mouthful, but it
fits the data presented in the paper.
This is again a picture from the
textbook enough to inference by Thomas
Parr, Karl Friston, and Giovanni
Pizzoulo. It's a cortical column. And
the errors you see here,
ascending and descending connections,
if by chance you're not familiar with
the framework they correspond to,
the ascending errors are prediction
errors and descending ones are
predictions. This is what they say in
the book, that there's an asymmetry in
message passing. And the reason for that
is that the operations required to
compute prediction error from
expectation are nonlinear. This
nonlinearity is due to computation of
predictions using nonlinear functions
that tend to increase the frequency of
the signal. I'd like to
talk a little bit about reduction. It
became very fashionable and sometimes
silly to use this like, oh, you're
reductionist. No, you're reductionist.
And the second most popular term is
oversimplify. You oversimplify. Now you
oversimplify. And to me, they're not bad
words. They're necessary tools to
simplify and to reduce. The map
that equals the territory exactly is
useless. Nobody's going to use it. It
must kind of I'm quoting James Quick
simplify and, you know, I'll illustrate
the specific term. If the car is moving
with a fixed velocity on a straight line
and if I know exactly where it is right
now, I can tell with certainty where it
has been an hour before. That is a
reduction in time. And I can do that
because the formula is linear. It's
distance equals velocity multiplied by
time and velocity is constant. If the
watch is broken and I disassemble it and
I find a faulty part and then I put it
back together and it works, then it's a
reduction in space. And I can do that
because watch is not an end colony to
use Daniel's terms. Watch is equal to
the collection of its parts. So I wanted
to talk about, Mark, your mention of the
predictive hierarchy composed of
billions of homeostats in your work.
This is approximate picture. This is not
the exact picture of what you talk about
in the new project. And this is from
your hidden spring. It's a predictive
hierarchy where predictions flow from
left to right and prediction errors from
right to left. And one of the statements
in the book in the Hidden Spring you say
that brain's many complex functions
really can ultimately be reduced to a
few simple mechanisms like this. So it
appears that you call it reduction.
But it is a powerful model. It is a
flexible model. I wanted to describe
some features of it. Well, first of all,
if homeostat is present at every single
scale, then we have this homogeneity of
mechanisms throughout the scales. And I
want to say that in physics things don't
look this way. Quantum mechanics is the
microphysics. Statistical mechanics is
molecular level. Newtonian mechanics is
heavenly bodies. And then we have
general theory of relativity. There's
qualitative shifts. There isn't a
homogeneity of mechanism all the way
throughout. In fact, when people say
take entanglement and they apply to
human beings, that's sort of a
misunderstanding of entanglement. The
second comment is from Mike Eleven who
talks about these scales. And if his
comment is that you could have different
functional spaces at every scale where
you could solve the genetic task on one
scale, electrochemical on another,
morphological on the third one. And then
how you do message passing, what is the
common language is not a trivial
question. Along the same lines,
I've already mentioned that a message
between the scales can be nonlinear if
you do prediction errors. Now if you
take one nonlinear message and then you
multiply it by billions, you're going to
have a full on turbulence, which is a
chaotic system, it's a dynamical system
and turbulence you cannot reduce to
homeostat or anything else. Saying that
water consists of H 20 does not explain
turbulence. So I don't know, that's an
open question. But I wanted to maybe
share some perceptions of this model.
This I talked about and this is the
Friston's thought about phase transition
and the attracting set. He said that if
you have a hierarchy of Lorenzo
tractors, a slower one and a faster one
and a slower one governing the
transitions of the faster Lorenzo
tractor, then you could have a FEP
formulation with an attracting set
experiencing changes and transitions.
And that's brilliant, I think. And it
matches the anatomy because the
brainstem and the subcortical structures
appear to be slower. Lorenzo tractor
that could be seen as governing the
transitions of the cortex, which is
astral Lorenzo tractor. I know I'm
oversimplifying things a great deal,
but it sort of misses his thoughts. I
think him and Lancelor de Costa are
working on that. Perhaps Maxwell
Ramstead's group is working on that as
well. The clinical applications, the
landscape that I've mentioned before
would be absolutely lovely to see if we
were to consider going there borderline
personality disorder or another term for
that could be complex trauma. The
metaphor that we use for these patients
is they're predictably unpredictable.
That the only thing we know on Wednesday
that we don't know what's going to come
up. Suggesting chaoticity acute trauma
has a symptom of hyperarousal,
suggesting possibly higher level of
chaoticity. An onset of mania can be
seen as a transition into a higher
energy state and addictions,
particularly with stimulants, can be
seen as phase transitions into a chaotic
state. It may sound like what I said now
is contradictory to what I said before
when I suggested that lower chaoticity
could be a problem, such as an onset of
a seizure. And here I'm saying higher
chaoticity can be a problem, but that
would only be a contradiction in the
linear world. In the real world, where
linear is very small percentage of
what's happening, I'm saying both that
too little and too much chaos could be a
problem. Just enough chaos imbalance
could be perfectly fine. This is a
graphical illustration of what can be
done. This is from my colleague and
friend David Pinkus, who is a professor
in Sheppin University and I think also
former president of the Society for
Chaos and Psychology Society. These are
trees. It may sound like completely
unrelated to what we do, except if you
look at a human lung or dendrites in a
neuron and you can see a healthy tree on
the right from me and a nearly dead tree
on the left. And if you do the fractal
assessment, fractal dimension assessment
on them by counting the thickness of
branches and count the number of
branches at each level, then you can
quantify and then you can have
approximate quantification of health and
resilience versus pathology.
And again, as exotic as it may sound,
this is very similar to what people do
when they detect a seizure on the AG.
They measure CD correlational dimension,
which is approximately fractal
dimension. And I think my
30 minutes are up. Thank you so much for
your attention.
Thank you, Lexi. Great presentation.
Well, looking forward to this
discussion. First, Mark, please feel
free to add your reflections. Then
Andrea, then we'll continue on.
Thanks very much.
When Alexi asked me if I would join this
panel, the first thing that I said to
him was yes, coupled with. The second
thing being, but please be aware that I
know next to nothing about chaos theory.
So I'm not sure how much
of a contribution I can make to a
technical discussion of this
kind. So I'm just repeating
that before I say anything else. If I
say anything that sounds amateur, that
sounds as if this guy doesn't know what
he's talking about when it comes to
chaos theory. It's because I'm an
amateur and I don't know what I'm
talking about when it comes to chaos
theory. That said,
the second thing I want to say is I'm
not entirely sure what is at stake here.
It seems as if Alexei feels that it's
really important that I
and our colleagues get our head
around chaos theory and bring some
of what it has to offer into
our field. Because I don't know much
about it. I don't know what's at stake,
you see. I don't know why that's
important. So perhaps somewhere
along the line in the next just less
than an hour that we have, perhaps,
Alexi, you can clarify that for us.
The third thing I wanted to say is,
and perhaps in order to illustrate the
first thing is that as Alexei was
talking now, it seemed as if he was
talking about chaos, as if it were
synonymous with stochasticity or
randomness. And that's not my
understanding. My very limited
understanding of chaos theory was that
it's not synonymous. Chaos, as used
in that science or in that theory,
is not synonymous with randomness. It's
rather synonymous with unpredictability.
Because we don't know the initial
conditions of the system, or we can't
specify all the variables with
sufficient precision in their initial
conditions, it becomes impossible to
predict. And because of the nature of
the interrelationships of the variables,
one tiny little error in your
estimation of the initial conditions can
lead to massive consequences. And this
is why it's so hard to predict
chaotic systems. So if that
is what is meant, then I would say,
Stuart, of course this applies to
the way that the mind works and the way
that the brain works. But that leads me
back to my second point. I'm not sure
what's at stake, but I would say, if
that's what you're asking, if that's
what you're claiming, rather, Alexey,
then I would say that surely must be so,
that it is exceedingly difficult to
predict mental and neural
events at any level of complexity.
Now, I think I've said three things.
Let me now say a fourth thing. I think
that a crucial well,
let me put it this way. Of course, what
the brain and mind are trying to
do, it's a matter of trying to
predict what's going to happen. So what
I've just said about how difficult it is
to predict what's going to happen in the
brain or mind it's almost the
same thing as to say that the mind
and brain are trying to model the world.
That's the main thing that we are trying
to do is have a good model
of the world so that we can get some
sort of grip on this chaos,
so that we can act rationally
in the sense that we can act in
order to preserve ourselves that we do
not dissipate by
just exploring all possible states and
no longer existing as a system. Because
we, as systems, need to remain within
certain bounds across a great many
variables. As you said, we can't
afford to just let shit happen and
throw ourselves to
its fates. We need to try to predict in
a very unpredictable world. What must I
do in order to meet this need, given how
the world works? So the brain is trying
to model the world. Our predictive model
is trying to synchronize itself with the
world. And for that reason it's going to
be very chaotic. But the
crucial point is it's trying to reduce
the unpredictability.
With that said, I'll make a fifth point,
or maybe it's another part of my fourth
point. No, I think it's a fifth point,
which is that the way that I
conceptualize the predictive model and
it's not me alone who does this is that
it is a hierarchical model. And I think
that's very important. And perhaps
here's where things do start, where it
starts to at least in my mind, I start
to see some of what's at stake. I think
that the more peripheral layers of the
predictive model I see the predictive
model not as a triangle, but rather
as an onion. So the core is the deepest
layers of the model. That is to say,
the layers that have the greatest
spatial and temporal generalizability
and they're the most stable layers of
the model. And as we move toward the
periphery, which coincides with the
periphery of the nervous system,
in other words, the encounter with the
outside world, so it
becomes more chaotic,
we can tolerate more unpredictability
at the periphery and
that also allows for greater accuracy
because the world is so unpredictable.
We have a more chaotic outer
layer of our predictive model where
things also there's less that's at
stake. Is that car going to turn left or
right? Well, I thought it was going to
turn left, turn right. So what? Doesn't
matter. But is the
car going to obey the laws of gravity
that matters more?
That's a much more consequential
surprise if it does not. And perhaps
that's a silly analogy, but at least it
illustrates the general point, our most
heartfelt beliefs,
and that is to say, the deepest
layers of our predictive hierarchy.
There we find the same patterns over and
again and we
are more certain of our predictions and
we act more stereotypically in
accordance with them, whereas at the
periphery that does not apply.
So I think at one point in your
presentation, Alexi, you were saying
something like one size doesn't fit all.
It's not all, just one mechanism. All
the way down. Of course, I completely
agree with that. It's not
just one mechanism. The different
homeostats that you were referring to on
there different scales are also serving
different needs and there's not a common
currency. I think that's a very
important part of how consciousness
works. Why we have qualia at all is
because we can't reduce things to a
common currency. We're dealing with
categorical variables, at the very
least, in relation to our bodily needs.
They are categorically distinct needs
and they need to be treated as such.
And this is why we have different
feelings in relation to these different
categories of free energy.
So those are some of the main things I
wanted to say just to get the ball
rolling. I'm mindful of the fact that
Andrea Clarici only has 15
more minutes with us. So maybe I
can pick up on some other points later.
But at this stage, let me hand over to
Andrea. Thank you.
Can you hear me now? Yes, sorry.
I will try also to articulate something
of the very fascinating paper of Alexia.
I must confess, since I'm also a
psychoanalytic psychotherapist, a
psychiatrist. It's not my field. I'm not
a physicist, so I can really say few
words. Some is of, as I said
already, fascination, because in
general, I hate to stick to rigid
theories. So if there is a paper like
Alexia who can chaoticize my theories,
even in psychoanalysis, in the workings
of the mind and the brain, I'm happy to
dive into it. At the same time,
I don't have the skills to discuss
the math part of his papers or even the
physical formulas and so on. But I
was reminded of a very early and I think
you all know that book Jacques Monot
Chance and Necessity, which is a
classic. And I think it's a book in
which you can from
scratch. I mean, here that our aim in
the world. And I know I'm
sounding theological, but we have
theological aims.
In order to stay alive, we have to face
chance and chaos. So I think this is in
order to survive and reproduce, we have
to have a mathematical
system to reduce chaos and to bring
up again determinism or psychic
determinism. Since one of the points
that Lexie, I think, raised is can
we still hold the point of Freud's about
psychic determinism? And I think if
you apply not to the physics of
just materialism.
Of. Things, actually, but to the living
organism, I think we do. This is my
point, and I would like to hear
what Alexia says. In the end, the chaos
theory. Mathematics,
as far as I understand it, must be a
mathematics who reduce chance or chaos
to a linearity, at least in the living
organism. And I wonder if and
what Alexia thinks about it,
because he seems to disagree with that.
Want to give a direct response, lexi or
then Brynn and Albert be awesome to hear
your takes as well, some of the thoughts
from Mark and from Andrea. Should I
start by responding to Andrea's points
or marks?
Maybe I'll start by because I think the
key point that Mark you brought up is
what's at stake is still unclear. My
impression is, and please correct me if
I'm wrong I was very influenced, Mark,
by your paper. I forgot exactly, the
journal where you talked about
psychiatry world, how these sort of
convention based diagnosis of here is a
major depressive disorder, here's a
bipolar disorder, nothing of which has
to do with etiology convention and
statistics. And then you brought up this
revolutionary thing with effective
neuroscience where you talked about the
manic state and the depression state and
tied into the punk subsystem, I think is
extraordinary. But what I wanted to say
is if we look at how we diagnose and
think about what's happening, and we
look at the language of how we do it,
it is still a deterministic language at
the end of the day. So when we moved
from DSM Four to DSM Five, we
brilliantly discovered that continuous
variables exist. We used to have
buckets. Everything was in a separate
bucket. And then we said autism is a
spectrum, and everybody applauded, but
mathematicians were quietly laughing in
the corner. Because, of course,
continuous variables exist, but we don't
do dynamics. We're still very static.
Here's this clear cut thing. And this is
the clear cut continuous thing, right?
And my impression I may be wrong, is
that even in our neuropsychoanalytic
developments, we still do things
deterministically. We assess which
bucket things belong to, or maybe two
buckets at the same time, or three
buckets. But we don't do things like how
the chaotic systems are qualitatively
different from static things. I'm
quoting William Solis. They have
transients, they have contextuality,
and they have emergence. We don't do
know. And I think that if we embrace the
chaos theory, if we do things like
correlational dimension assessment or
fractal dimension assessment, starting
from the system of classification of
emotions, they're still buckets. Here is
a clear cut thing called fear. That's a
clear cut thing called rage. Buckets
determinism, okay? And they look
differently in the dynamical systems
world. And then the system of
psychopathology could look like
correlational dimension changed and not
that somebody fell into a bucket. If we
look at this complex landscape of
attractors and repellers and examine
psychodynamic things like please forgive
me if I'm incorrect, but one of the
possible definitions of repression could
be seen as not letting things into
consciousness. Maybe we can call it
suppression. But what I'm trying to say
is I don't want to think that right now.
It hurts. It's a painful thing that in
the terminology that I shared, is a
repeller. And perhaps when you work
through things in a psychodynamic,
psychotherapy, perhaps you put a scar
tissue on the wound, it becomes less of
a sharp repeller, and it smooths
out. We don't diagnose like
that. We don't treat like that. We don't
think like that. One paper that I'm
working on that is in peer review right
now and I can't share too much, says
that we think like storytellers. I'm
quoting Daniel Kahneman. Our thinking
mind of a clinician is not a
statistician. We don't think in
probabilities, we think in labels and we
think in stories. And I know you had
this powerful quote, Mark, from Freud
who said that that's the nature of the
mind. And I most respectfully disagree
that that's the entire nature of the
mind. I do think that we have things on
the mind that are not stories and not
words. So if the nature of the
phenomenon is chaotic and stochastic and
periodic, then we can use appropriate
mechanisms to diagnose and classify that
fits the nature of the model. The second
thing you said chaos and stochasticity,
I absolutely agree with you that they're
different. On the chart that I've shown,
if you converge to a stable,
chaos is deterministic, forward
deterministic. So if initial conditions
are changing, they will diverge. But you
can predict things forward, not back.
But there is no formula in a stochastic
thing, you throw the coin. You don't
know. You have no predictability
whatsoever, short term or third or long
term. So they are different. And in the
sense that you're talking to
sensitivity, to initial conditions,
this is music to my heart to hear you to
say that you acknowledge that
curioticity clearly is present in the
brain, on which level of the hierarchy
in your model is a very important thing.
But again, when we draw this picture,
whether it's a triangle or an onion with
a core and layers, it's a static model.
And when you acknowledge that there's
higher unpredictability toward the
periphery, it could be, but there could
be dynamics about the structure of the
model. And perhaps what you're saying is
survival. Like I must breathe and I
must breathe air and I'm not in the
water. And that is a very stable
prediction. Absolutely. But when we deal
with psychopathology and we deal with
things like shame and pride and awe and
other things, then I wonder if we should
continue to use this metaphor of a
homeostat. I really don't see how
homeostat applies to gamma written in
the brain or to shame. And homeostat
is the convergent systems so that you
minimize entropy by keeping things in
the range. However, if you dive inside
the homeostat, if you look at the
temperature variation inside a narrow
range, you may see chaos, which is
exactly the picture that I saw,
that I showed.
And to Andrea's point about
the Freud's principle of psychic
determinism yes, I honestly think that
we haven't said goodbye to that. We
haven't tried to say that chance exists
in the mental life. Accidents exist.
We don't do that. There's a firm
tradition in psychoanalytic,
psychotherapy, to say there's no
accidents it's all determined. That's a
major key point of the discussion. I
don't know if I said too much.
Maybe, andrea, if you want to give any
thoughts or how do you want things to
continue in the coming minutes and
years? Okay, thank you. Thank you,
Daniel. Just adding a word that I didn't
use because I think it's very important
about trying to defend the point about
psychic determinism, which I'm very fond
of. I mean, the word is adaptation. I
have difficulties because when you see a
psychotic patient, when you see a
borderline patient, well, I don't see
chaos or total unpredictability.
I see adaptation, their disruptions.
I try to understand what are
the even the part
behind that, in my opinion, has to
have a tendency toward
an order, which is adaptive. In this
way, I see the mathematical part
of chaos may be of use, but bringing
to an explanation maybe not to an order
or to a determinism, but to a point
in which there must be this adaptive
reason even in the chaos. Do you see my
point? I do. But I think
there's a deeper issue about how we
know. Say there's a clinician
psychoanalytic psychotherapist. We have
a working memory. And the Miller's law
that, Mark, you quote a lot about the
seven units of information in the audio
verbal work in memory. I think in the
Miller's paper, he actually said seven
chunks. So I'm sharing something from
the paper in Review right now. We cannot
think probabilistically because it
overloads the work in memory. This is
why when I'm a clinician, I think about
psychosis, I come up with a story, a
formulation that fits in the work in
memory, and this influences our work.
We don't have the mathematics in here to
think in the terms of probabilistic
things and chaos theory and other
things. We need tools to do that. And in
mainstream neurology, they use tools.
They do talk to the patient that examine
the patient. But they have MRI, they
have EHE, they have Pescan and all the
other things. In psychoanalytic
psychotherapy, we say, we don't need any
tools. We just talk to a person, and
that is sufficient for everything we do.
But that's not necessarily true.
Beatrice Bibi, who is a psychoanalyst,
works with mother infant diet, and
there's zero words exchanged zilch. But
she looks at this movie that she records
on a video camera, and then she shows it
in a slow motion. So she takes a flow,
which is dynamic flow, not words, not
discrete things. And then she slows it
down and she shows the level of
attunement between the mother and the
child. We don't do things like that.
We talk and we use these deterministic
things to understand the psychopathology
of the patient, saying that's psychosis
and that's schizophrenia, and that is
bipolar one. This is panic system and
this is seeking system. We determine
everything. And that is a limitation
because inside, I believe what is a fear
cascade? How does fear stop? It's a
flow. It's a turbulent thing. And we put
one label on it, say fear. We've
classified it. So for some things it's
appropriate, but for some things, it may
not be, as Einstein said,
as Mark. You quoted Einstein as simple
as possible, but more simpler than that.
So at which point we are missing or
missing the phenomenon by using
deterministic tools in our work. Thank
you, Alex. Thank you. Thank you, Daniel
and Mark. To everyone. Thank you. I have
to go. Awesome. So Albert
and then Brynn and we'll continue on
this topic. Yeah, thank you
for the presentation and a very
interesting discussion so far. One thing
that comes to mind is. The.
Well, the thing we're talking about
right now, the psychic determinism as
depicted as being a foundational law in
psychoanalysis.
Well, I'm thinking about the authors,
the psychoanalytic authors who came the
prominent ones who came after Freud,
who seem to. Have.
Room for this chaos.
Maybe they didn't use this term
explicitly, but I'm thinking, for
example, Wilfred Bjong, who's got the
notion of the O layer, which has
connotations of well, the thing that
cannot be known or categorized, who has,
like, indeterminate elements of the
mind. And that's one of his major
contributions to psychoanalysis. On the
other hand, more the French schools.
I'm thinking of Jacques Lacan, who's got
the notion of the real, which is also
one of his major contributions to
psychoanalysis, where notions of
rupture, of absence, or of lack are very
prominent. I'm not sure I'm not an
expert here, but I think Lacan
explicitly challenges the notion of
Freud's mechanistic worldview in one of
his seminars. So I'm wondering what you
think about this, Alexei.
I'm not an expert in Lacan at all, and I
know Wilfred beyond in a limited
fashion. So perhaps Mark is a better
person to talk.
And I like Freud. Particularly mark's
interpretations and translations. But
maybe Mark can comment on Lacan and
beyond. I'm not sufficiently
knowledgeable about their work.
If you want to Mark or Bren, you can
share some thoughts. Yeah, please.
Well, I think that the
point that Albert's making is we
must remember that psychoanalysis is not
synonymous with Freud. That not
everything in psychoanalysis stands or
falls by whether or not we accept this
or that tenet of Freud's. And in
neuropsychoanalysis, we try very much to
draw upon all of the traditions within
psychoanalysis. And we sort of fondly
believe that we'll be able to find more
common ground because there are greater
empirical tools available in
neuropsychoanalysis than in
psychoanalysis by itself. We are hoping
to resolve some of these theoretical
disagreements, trying to move beyond
just different systems of belief,
trying to move more toward a
psychoanalysis in which we can decide
questions in an ordinary scientific way.
But it will always be very difficult for
exactly the reason that Alexei's whole
talk is about, I suppose, which is the
extreme complexity and therefore
unpredictability of the phenomena that
we are dealing with. So I think Albert's
points are valid. That the beyond's
approach, Lacan's approach,
they add a great deal.
They don't have as much to lose
if we throw out the principle of
psychical determinism. But having said
that, let me just quickly say a word
about psychical determinism, because
this has been a big part of what Andrea
picked up on in what Alexey said.
I think it comes down to the
question that I asked at the outset.
It's not a matter of is the behavior of
the mind random or it's
a question of how predictable. It's not
a matter of is there no determinism?
It's a matter of how easily can we trace
effects back to their causes. So the
fact that there's a great deal that goes
on where we can't do that. There are
many things our patients say, whether
they be slips of the tongue or anything
else of that kind, and not only to do
with parapraxes, but anything that they
do. There are certain things that we see
with regularity. I mean, the very
phenomenon of transference is all about
regularities. That there are certain
things that we see. Yes,
I can understand this
happens repeatedly.
I think I can explain that with
reference to certain aspects of the
patient's inner world and their past,
but there's a great deal else that we
can't. So I don't think that it's a kind
of either there's determinism
or there's stochasticity. I think
that this is why I was talking also
about the layers of the predictive
hierarchy. The deeper layers are the
unconscious ones. Their things are
pretty stereotyped,
pretty predictable, in fact,
too predictable. I mean, in other words,
it over generalizes, it's too confident
about its beliefs. But as we head toward
the pre conscious and conscious there,
things are much less predictable.
So I won't say more.
A couple of things in what Alexei said
in his comments after mine, that if we
have time, I'll come back to but I think
let's rather hear from Brin before I say
anything more. Thank you so much.
I'm perhaps the least qualified here to
comment on your paper, Alexi, but I do
have one or two thoughts, and they come
from a place of being very fortunate
thus far in my life to have been a
patient for many, many hours,
sometimes on the couch, and also to be a
clinical psychologist. I failed to
mention that in my introduction. So I'm
a was until recently,
when my foray began into more research
based areas, and via the Active
Inference Institute and Mark's work and
Cole Friston's work, I was a pure
clinician. I had it in my mind that I
was going to treat psychopathology to
the best of my ability. But really it
was being a patient first and foremost
that brought me into closer contact with
the theme of your paper and certainly
the themes of Mark's work.
And I think I've
encountered it from both areas. And
certainly to
my mind, it matters less the inner
workings of the degree to which chaos
stochastic, all these big wonderful
terms that I'm only beginning to even
think about. But.
What matters to me is that how
do you help somebody who is
in a state, who comes in disheveled?
And how does one go about helping aiding
somebody in that state? I fell
out of love with psychoanalysis for
personal reasons, but it was in
returning to it, I've become more kind
of better acquainted with its strengths
and its limitations. And I'm realizing
that when
you help somebody and manage to reduce
the noise, to reduce the chaos in
somebody's mind,
when they become the greater degrees of
health start returning to them, that
they do rely far more, whether they know
it or not, on probabilistic reasoning in
their daily kind of functioning.
And so I think there is a strong case to
be made for a mathematical way
of processing the world. It doesn't have
to necessarily be made conscious to the
person. It can be a bit overwhelming to
try and impart that on somebody. But I
think a brain that is not working
properly, regardless of the degree to
which there is chaos, that can be
measured or quantifiably measured in
that brain, somebody is tripping over
themselves because they are
unable to predict what might happen.
And that is a terrifying prospect
because I think there is some reliance
and some staunch dependability on the
fact that the sun is going to rise and
that it's going to set and that I can
then focus on other things.
So that's just my comments more from
kind of a personal front of being a
patient and encountering the limitations
of psychotherapy and what I
would have done in those moments of need
to have not, as you say,
had a more deterministic view of
what was happening. And I've tried to
transfer that or carry that over,
rightly or wrongly, into my own therapy
as a psychotherapist.
So a more personal thing of what it
means to be feel chaotic and what I
see, regardless of how confirmed it is
or not, but chaos reigns
and to try and not compound
that is certainly something that I'm
interested. Yeah. Thank you, Bryn.
I'll also give my thought on what's at
stake and what's on the table as a total
non clinician. But what I saw in Alexi's
paper and also what I see people coming
towards I see the paper as Alexi
making a real stable of concepts
or portfolio of topics ranging from the
first principles of active inference
like surprise bounding, to dynamic
stochastic chaotic, which not the same
thing, but they sometimes cohabitate.
So bringing a set of concepts into play,
making it matter for the field so that
it can matter for the clinician, so that
it can matter for the patient, which is
where you totally brought it home to
Brin. And in my totally simplified
model, I was seeing all this diagnostic
machinery from personalized data, EEG
recordings, all these surveys and
samples, all the different conversation
therapy itself, all these different
measurements, inference. And then it
passes through the Markov blanket of the
diagnosis, and it's like, well, now we
know that that person is X or they have
X. And then here's where we now branch
back out with modalities of treatment.
And so that bottlenecking has obvious
relevance in terms of getting a
categorical grip on what we basically
all agree are wetware complex systems,
they're sensitive to initial conditions,
all of that. And what if, though, like
you brought up the example with the scar
tissue, maybe it's literal bodily scar
tissue, maybe it's conceptual scar
tissue. What if that inference were able
to be understood in the context of an
attractor landscape? And it's not just a
singular attractor, so we have multiple
attractors, we have a chaotic landscape.
And so what if we were able to perforate
that blanket, speaking super loosely,
to bring in what we have already
recognized as diagnostically relevant?
Like the fact that patients who have
differential entropy have this or that
epileptic outcome or coma outcome,
bring in that machinery that led to the
diagnosis, but now take it beyond the
diagnosis and maybe even beyond the
clinician's concept, directly into the
hands of the patient?
Thank you so much. Perhaps we can hear
from Mark and yeah, I'm not eager to
talk. If there is time, I'll say
something, but if not, that's OK.
Well, let me first of all say something
about my might.
Some of you have noticed that suddenly
everything went black behind me. That's
because I'm in South Africa where they
have power problems. And then a kind
person in my household thought that they
would help. And they've put this huge
spotlight here which is shining in my
eyes.
If I look as if I'm in a rabbit in
headlights, it's because I am. I sent a
text message saying, please come and
remove this big lamp you put here. But
they don't seem to have received the
message. Now back to our actual
topic. To the extent
that I'm able to not be distracted from
it, I think that when I asked
Alexi what was at stake, his main answer
was to do with a diagnosis. Now, I don't
mean that he's saying that that's all
that's at stake, but I think he's saying
this illustrates what's at stake.
So I want to first of all make sure that
because I'm not sure who our audience is
and who's going to be watching this in
case anybody misunderstands,
I want to make clear that in
psychoanalysis, we've long ago moved
away from DSM and ICD type diagnosis.
We always thought that the
psychiatric nozology was wholly
artificial and created divisions
where they don't exist in nature. And we
replaced it with a far more dynamic.
Approach to diagnosis. And it's not just
a matter of labeling. It's a matter also
of what kind of thought process lies
behind the diagnosis. In other words,
conceptualizing what's going on here,
rather than saying, this is an instance
of personality disorder, and I'll
specify which type, we don't think like
that in psychoanalysis, and really, we
never have in neuropsychoanalysis.
We build in that same tradition.
I think that what Alexei was
worrying about. He's saying, yeah, but
you use systems, you say that
there's a certain number of drives and
you use those to pass what you're seeing
clinically. And yes, we do,
and we have to, because you can't just
say, what I'm seeing is chaos. What
you've got to say is, well, what I'm
seeing is chaos, but let me try my best
to find the deeper structure of this.
And so what we do is much the same as
what I was saying earlier about how
brain and mind work. Likewise, the
clinician's mind works. That way we have
some deeper concepts that organize what
we see, and then more on the surface,
we see the complexity. In other words,
we don't think that we can reduce a
patient just to one saying, this patient
has problems with this drive, or
something. It's not as simple as that,
of course, but we do start with saying,
well, these are the drives, these are
the attractors. To put it in terms
of the attractor landscape that you're
talking about, these are the preferred
states of the human phenotype.
And in mental life too, they are
preferred states. There are certain
attractors that we're trying to stay
in. Those like, for example,
fear. We want to be safe, we don't want
to feel fear. With respect to attachment
bonding, we want to stay close to our
attachment figures. We don't want to
lose them. With respect to rage, we
don't want to be frustrated and have
things standing in our way. We want to
be able to have free access to the
objects of our needs and so on. Those
are these attractors, and we have great
difficulty staying in those homeostatic
bounds. It is a dynamic
picture. And then over the question of
the different drives, there's the highly
individualized predictive model that
each one of us comes up with in relation
to those drives and in relation to the
conflicts between those drives and so
on. So I think that this
way of thinking that we use in
psychoanalysis and neuropsychoanalysis
is already of the kind that Alex is
calling for. So I think that what
Daniel's just said is therefore perhaps
very important to make clear it's that
he's offering us a language, an
additional language, an additional I
don't just mean language, I should say
an additional set of concepts and
a highly developed one, which we might
find useful. And so we should take this
on board. That sounds very convincing to
me, if that's what's at stake here.
That Alexei is saying this is a language
that lends itself to the phenomena that
you study and to the way in which you go
about studying it, then it sounds to me
as if Alexi is right. So that's the main
thing I wanted to say in response to his
comments in relation to what I said.
So if anyone else wants to say anything
else, that's good with me. But Alexi,
if I've misunderstood and if there's
something else that you think is at
stake that I'm not getting, now's your
chance to say it.
Well, I just wanted to end the
conversation when you said that if this
language might be of any even to
consider this language in our future
models, I'm a happy man and there's
nothing else I need to say. And I
just wanted to say that these are human
things. They're occupational hazards.
Some of the things I'm talking about,
this paper I'm working on about
narrative stuff, is that, of course,
it is much easier for us to think in
categories, even in the psychoanalytic
world. What we do let's
take the Macquillium system and the
previous one. We used to say three
levels of functioning neurotic,
borderline psychotic. These are
categories. They're not DSM categories.
They're not bipolar one, but they're
categories nonetheless. Then we have
character styles, obsessive character
style, histrionic character style.
They're categories. Okay? So to some
degree, it's a human condition to put
things in categories. And I do think
that this is a very strong historical
reasons that we think this way.
We have generations of thinking this way
in categories. And yes, at the end of
the day, when we paint a portrait of a
patient, it's developed, and it's like a
tapestry. All of these things weave into
one another, and it's complex, but we
start from basic categories. And
certainly if we consider that some
things can be transient, there can be
emergence, they're like that. Certain
behavior in one context is a compulsion,
but it's not a compulsion in another
context. And perhaps I'm saying trivial
things to clinicians and also
what dream you said just to comment when
you said as a patient to reduce the
noise and reduce the chaos. I detect the
bias in the language. You see how we
call psychopathology in DSM disorders.
Disorder is a bad word for us. And I'm
trying to say chaos is healthy. I spend
most of my day in gamma functioning,
which is a chaotic state. It's not a bad
thing. So in the folk language, chaos is
a bad word. Disorder is a bad I want to
put things in order, and then perhaps
we're missing something. What comes to
mind is, I think, Mark, you had meetings
with Michael Levin and Ian McGilchrist,
who know big on talking about the
mechanistic, logical, linear, straight
and narrow left hemisphere type. Of
course it's not left hemisphere, but
that's the model versus holistic
sensorial kind of right hemisphere
artistic type. And we're missing the
second part, like Daniel's background is
surrounded by art where we
spend less time in the right hemisphere,
maybe appropriately so, but I think that
there's some things that lend themselves
to that level of understanding and we
break things. We look at psychopathology
and a human suffering like it's a
carburetor sometimes, where we again put
it in buckets. That's my impression.
But what you said is wonderful and I
don't contradict with anything. I agree
with everything you said, Mark.
Alexi, if I can just comment.
It'S. Almost like an arc. The pot of
gold at the end of the arc is the
reduced chaos, the reduced noise in
terms of the patients from the patient's
perspective. But how you get there,
ironically, is actually by inducing
states of tolerable chaos
and then kind of reformulating that,
reconsolidating that chaos. So it's not
that from the healing or growth or
whatever the patient might present to
you for it has everything to do with
minimal or marginal chaos induction and
then reintegration of that.
So the whole process is premised on
chaos, but in bite sized doses, maybe
one could say, right, and just to.
Finish up and then I'll stop talking.
Jonathan Schadler, who all know and
know, widely respected as a
psychoanalytic practitioner and teacher
and writer, he recently said that take a
patient X with an analyst Y together the
diet has emergent properties. That is
not the same thing as patient X with the
analyst Z. Right? And show me one study
where we take that into account. We
don't. We just do random clinical
trial, then we do metaanalysis of random
clinical trial. What technique did the
therapist use? They used, you know,
whatever four letter therapy they
applied. Nobody looks at the emerging
properties in a diet. This matrix
between the two, and that's the language
of dynamical systems. This is Daniel
Friedman ant colony. A single ant
doesn't build bridges and grow
mushrooms. Ant colony does all those
things. We don't talk about emergence in
psychoanalytic psychotherapy, do we?
It's true. It's also a fundamental
challenge. After all, you can't
replicate within one Dyad or across
Dyads in a finite world. So it does
point to fundamentals. In our last
minutes, if each would like to
give some thoughts, where do we go as we
now the opponent of exponent away from
each other in our paths? So maybe
Albert, Brynn, Mark and then Alexey,
what are your overall thoughts,
reflections? And then where are we
heading?
Go for it, Albert.
Yeah, I was about to comment on Alexey
about the emergent properties thing.
It's kind of the same point I made
earlier. Later psychoanalytic
theories do talk about emergent
properties. But yes, I think as what
Professor Salvage just mentioned.
This new set of. Concepts makes it very
practical for us to communicate with
each other because psychoanalysis has a
bad habit of reinventing new concepts
every new decade. So there's a lot of
chaos to use that word within
psychoanalytic discourse.
But overall, I thought I'm very
grateful. I think this was a very
interesting talk. So yeah. Thank you.
Thank you. Yes. By way of closing
remarks, I agree with
actually, it seems to me that there's an
abundance of agreement in this meeting.
I don't see any big controversy.
So that's nice.
I think what Brynn said really
captures it. I liked it because what he
said was so experience near. He was just
describing what it feels like to be a
patient,
to be in a state of not knowing and
uncertainty as opposed to a more stable
kind of tranquility. And then
the ability to allow
yourself to return to uncertainty if
you've found answers that are too
simple and that are too static
to allow ourselves to go back into this
state of not really knowing.
That, I think, really does describe what
we try to do for our patients. What we
have to remember applies to ourselves
not only because we are ultimately
patients too, but because it applies to
how the mind works. It applies to
science, how science works, that we
do need to find order, but there
is disorder out there. And so we're
always at risk of coming prematurely
to a rigid system of belief and we have
to return back to the coalface and back
to the chaos. But ultimately, where we
want to be is back in that valley.
And so, as much as Alex is right
to remind us that the
highest levels of brain activity in many
senses of the word are entropic
and that deep sleep and seizures
are bad things, as much as
that's true. Nevertheless, I think that
the great trend of the mind it's one of
its fundamental working principles is we
are wanting to be more certain. We want
life to be more predictable. We don't
like to be in chaos. And I think that
that's an important thing
to remember while we are acknowledging
the importance of chaos and of
the highly unpredictable nature of the
world and of the phenomena we study in
our field, nevertheless, we retreat from
it, and for very good reasons.
So those are my closing remarks. And
thank.
And I'll be very brief. Alexia,
just thank you for the paper and for
having such a strong focus on the
patient and on psychopath well, on the
human condition. I think that's so nice
to have that come out of the
paper when at first glance it doesn't
seem to be there. So thanks for making
it so human and then just Daniel for
organizing and to spend time with Mark
and Albert. It's a great pleasure. So
thank you very much.
Alexi, final words. I want
to thank everybody and Mark and Brynn
and Albert and Daniel, Andrea, thank
you. I had a great fun and I'm very
grateful, honestly, for your help and
openness and flexibility. One of the
other reasons is kind of the time we
live in Yuval harari made that comment
that the rate of change is accelerating.
When we were hunter gatherers,
uncertainty was norm. You wake up,
there's nothing in the fridge. You have
to go hunt. And we tolerated uncertainty
better. We could put our worldly
possessions on the back. And then we
started living in the world of iPads.
iPhones were bombarded with information.
And we must minimize uncertainty. We
must have predictability in everything,
which is not the natural world for
mammals. And now we live our life and
then bang, COVID hits, and then bang,
certain person becomes the President of
the United States and everything goes
upside down. So the black swans are
hitting us more frequently. So I think
having the theory of that at our
fingerprint and applying it to our work
is probably beneficial. But again,
thank you all so much. I really
appreciate it. Awesome. Well, thank you
all for joining. The conversation
continues, so till next time.
Thank you. Bye bye. Thanks a lot.